đặc lắm đồng cũng là hai địa phương đang tiếp tục ngập lột nghiêm trọng.
Chúng điểm qua đến sang này nước lùa hả dù các sả phía đồng của tình đặc lắc đã a dút
khoảng hai mẹc và suốt thêm sẽ tiếp tục dút trong ngày hôm nay
tinh nhiên thì một số nơi vẫn còn đáng bị nghiệp nặng và chia các hoàn toàn như đây là hù vực tây hoa.
Cô vực này thì vẫn còn nơi mưa tò, lúc lụ trên các sông vẫn ở mức bảo động hai, bảo độc bà,
nên khả năng ngập lột vẫn sẽ kéo dài, vực tử nạn chú hộ cho bà con ở đây là thằng thêm khó khăn
và phòng viên hoàn thư sẽ nơi tên tiền trường trong sản này.
Hãy là một trong những khu vực chúng thấp của các sả phía đồng tình đặc khác
vì vậy mà tình trọng ngập lột đã diễn ra nhiều ngày,
và đến hệ hả năng này thì nhiều lực lượng cú hộ của trở mới có thể tiếp cận được người dân.
Trong hôm qua và sản này được lượng quốc sự con khu năng đã điều động
được lượng và rất nhiều phương tiện xung máy ca nô chờ lúc tự tự nhiên vùng có tăng bị gập nặng,
giúp tình hoa phủ hòa, phía nạn đồng hòa,
đồng thời gian chuyển gần rất nộ bùng gập sâu tự nơi cao sản trọng.
Truy nhiên tự tiếp bệnh họm rất vất lợp,
mưa tong chẳng sản vứ dự bảo lên tự hộ bột chăm 5,000 mệt trong 1 tuần giả bối sẽ làm năng quốc hợp được trở lại.
Trong hà bất lúc, mình là bước lợp lợp là hại thì hình hình đá có chắc tổ ngon cà nô
có chán mổ chính sĩ của tiêu nộ trong lòng là đang nơi rất cật là giới dời bà con.
và hưởng người chiến lực lực lượng cai ngôn lại vấn tiêu đút hoa,
họn vòng lớn trọc, tại các kê khu hợp.
Chứ có hoàn quốc dơ chỉ còn lại như thế này.
Không thật lúc này tính là tính tự.
Vì là thật tỏng hoàn bởi vì người ba mà mà mà như thế.
Đôi mấy lần được mục xì mấy cái đủ cũng do hả?
Chưa các cuộc số, tốt cái cuộc thế, nhưng được qua nhiều buồn lũ dữ,
có thể được những khắc chạy dài.
Sẽ tuy em mắt, là cắn năm người chết, lống người mất tất.
Và cùng xuống này đã tình lịch là xíc gạm lăng hơn.
Hẳn chết thật nhóc xong người chết.
Cô về nhiều người vẫn còn nơi sau trong lỗi anh.
Và là những chà hất xúc cũng tru.
Cái nhiều người dân mặc đẹp ngon con mình em lýu.
Cái gì không?
Dạ, mấy nó...
Nó mà em rõ, nó cháo nơi.
Những cổ mập sau như hà trị này.
Hôm nay, cái tình lắt lắc của cua năng phải.
Không nhiều lực lực hát vằng đi tụp ở đây, cũng dân.
Cũng dân và nó lực lấy dân lực ấm nó sơ nhìn này.